[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrigerin guten Abend ihnen allen das
sportliche Update später wieder mit Rudi
Cerne hallo schönen guten Abend und wir
schauen jetzt gemeinsam auf die heutigen
Themen
Michael Gorbatschow ein Reformer der den
Lauf der Geschichte veränderte jetzt ist
der Friedensnobelpreisträger und
Wegbereiter der deutschen Einheit
gestorben
Russland stoppt erneut seine
Gaslieferungen nach Deutschland Experten
schauen trotzdem vorsichtig optimistisch
Richtung Winter
und letzter großer Auftritt im
Tenniszirkus unter Tränen beendete
Andrea Petkovic bei den US Open ihre
Karriere
[Musik]
mit ihm verbinden sich einschneidende
emotionale Erinnerungen und epochale
politische Ereignisse nach dem Tod des
früheren sowjetischen Staatschefs
Michael Gorbatschow schauen wir auf
Reaktionen sein Leben und Vermächtnis
der Mann der half den Kalten Krieg zu
beenden und den Weg für die deutsche
Einheit ebnete verstarb gestern im Alter
von 91 Jahren
Gabi wie er in Deutschland liebevoll
genannt wurde lehrte die Welt zwei
russische Vokabeln Glasnost und
Perestroika Offenheit und Umbau das
brachte den Menschen in seinem Land zwar
nie dagewesene Freiheiten sein Versuch
aber das marotisch wirtschaftliche
politische System vor dem Zerfall zu
retten scheiterte viele dort machen ihn
bis heute für den Untergang der
Sowjetunion verantwortlich Anne Gerlinde
geändert
der im Westen gefeierte Reformer war an
seinem Lebensende in Russland ein
einsamer Mann er musste mit ansehen wie
seinen nach Nachfolger Vladimir Putin
sein Lebenswerk Schritt für Schritt
demontierte
die peristroika ist abgebrochen worden
jetzt geht es wieder rückwärts aber
Wladimir Putin wird damit keinen Erfolg
haben es wird ihm nicht gelingen nur mit
Angst und Schrecken zu regieren hoffte
Gorbatschow bis zum Schluss
1931 wird er in diesem Haus in
stavroupol in Südrussland geboren seine
Eltern sind Bauern der gelehrige Sohn
macht eine steile Karriere in der
Kommunistischen Partei steigt zum
gebietssekretär auf und geht schließlich
nach Moskau zuständig für Landwirtschaft
1985 wird er als jüngstes Politbüro
Mitglied zum Generalsekretär der
Kommunistischen Partei bestimmt und mit
ihm weht ein frischer Wind durch die
verkrustete Sowjetunion in
atemberaubendem Tempo beendet er den
Kalten Krieg er trifft sich mit dem
amerikanischen Präsidenten Ronald Reagan
schlägt vor die Atomwaffen zu halbieren
und stimmt der deutschen
Wiedervereinigung zu
1990 treffen sich Bundeskanzler Kohl und
Staatschefs Gorbatschow zum
strickjackengipfel im Kaukasus um die
Details der deutschen Einigung
auszuhandeln
im Westen ist Gabi ein gefeierter Held
zusammen mit seiner Frau Raisa bezaubert
er die ganze Welt
innenpolitisch aber bleibt Gorbatschow
glücklos er versteht nichts von Ökonomie
der Niedergang ist nicht aufzuhalten die
Wirtschaft bricht zusammen die
Sowjetunion zerfällt die Russen
assoziieren fortan Demokratie mit Chaos
Gorbatschow verliert die Macht an den
neuen starken Mann Boris Jelzin in
Russland ist der Reformer zu einer
tragischen Figur geworden
seinen 80 geburtstag feierte Michael
Gorbatschow in London in der Royal
Albert Hall auf Gratulanten aus dem
Kreml wartete der Mann der die Welt
veränderte vergebens
wir gehen zu für Bega nach moskaube
Präsident Putin der regiert autoritär
und wenig demokratisch so ziemlich das
Gegenteil dessen was Gorbatschow für
sich für seine Landsleute wünschte wie
reagiert Russland auf den Tod von
Gorbatschow
ich würde die Reaktionen heute als
ziemlich unterkühlt beschreiben große
öffentliche Trauer Wohnung die gab es
hier nicht in Russland wird Gorbatschow
sehr viel kritischer gesehen als im
westlichen Ausland die Russinnen und
Russen die haben nicht vergessen die
Armut und das Chaos die auf die
Reformpolitik von Gorbatschow in den
Neunzigern folgten aber natürlich gibt
es auch hier die Menschen die mit
Gorbatschow die Hoffnung auf eine
friedliche auf eine freiere Zukunft
verbinden oder verbunden haben aber die
sind in der Minderheit und viele haben
wohl auch angesichts des heutigen Kurses
von Russland resigniert andere sind
verängstigt die Schnittmenge zwischen
Gorbatschows Anhängern und Putins
Kritikern die dürfte ziemlich groß sein
und deswegen ist es auch interessant zu
beobachten wer dann am Samstag
öffentlich sich zu den Werten für die
Gorbatschow stand bekennen wird dann
findet nämlich die Beisetzung von
Gorbatschow in Moskau statt
grammelsprecher- der hat heute noch
gesagt dass Gorbatschow einen
romantischen Blick auf den kollektiven
Westen gehabt habe dass man aber
mittlerweile verstanden habe wie
blutrünstig die Gegner in Wirklichkeit
sein und da sieht man dann auch schon
dass Tod von Gorbatschow 4 verwendet
wird um weiter gegen den Westen Stimmung
zu machen vielen Dank für begann aus
Moskau so also der Blick aus russischer
Sicht weltweit hat der Tod von Michael
Gorbatschow Menschen berührt ganz
besonders in Deutschland was haben
Politiker hierzulande gesagt oder
geschrieben was denken Bürgerinnen und
Bürger im Osten und Westen Deutschlands
wir haben einige Stimmen
zusammengestellt stellvertretend für
viele heute den haben wir viel zu
verdanken
wenn Herr Putin dran gewesen wäre was
nicht sowas gegangen er hat sich alles
ein bisschen geebnet für uns alle und
hat uns als Mut gemacht zu diesem
Schritt zu gehen und wir fanden die
Ihnen als Menschen unterschreiblich toll
er war ein Mensch und kein Held und ich
muss sagen wenn Gorbatschow nicht
gewesen wäre und nicht die 4+1 Gespräche
so wie sie stattgefunden haben werden
wir heute nicht da wo wir jetzt sind
er war ein mutiger Reformer und ein
Staatsmann der vieles gewagt hat
wir werden nicht vergessen dass
Demokratie und Freiheit in Europa
möglich geworden sind dass Deutschland
vereint werden konnte und der Eiserne
Vorhang verschwunden ist
ich habe Hochachtung vor dem Mann seiner
Zeit gehabt und hätte sag ich mal in der
Zeit des Kalten Krieges nieder daran
gedacht
dass man mit Russland oder mit den
sowjet-staaten im Grunde genommen sage
ich mal wieder so ein gutes Verhältnis
wieder kriegt ich habe viele viele
Zeitepochen erlebt vom Zweiten Weltkrieg
Bomben die DDR die Wende direkt an der
Grenze und ich glaube wenn er nicht
gewesen wäre ich weiß nicht wo wir dann
jetzt wären
schöne stimmen die wir gehört haben wie
bedeutend Michail Gorbatschow für
Deutschland war und darüber hinaus das
fast auch eine ZDF-Dokumentation
zusammen die sie in unserer Mediathek
finden der Titel der Mann der die Welt
verändert
[Musik]
Energiekrise rekordinflation und
schlechte Stimmung nach Fehlern bei der
gasumlage die ampelregierung befindet
sich in stürmischer See hat sich aber
bei ihrer Kabinettsklausur demonstrative
Harmonie verordnet die Wogen zumindest
vor den Kameras geglättet der Kanzler
kündigte ein maßgeschneidertes
Entlastungspaket an allerdings ohne
Details zu nennen Patricia Wiedemeier
von den verbalen Attacken der letzten
Tage und Wochen hier in Meseberg nach
außen hin keine Spur man arbeite besten
zusammen habe sich untergehakt so der
Kanzler und Finanzminister der
Vizekanzler ging sogar noch weiter und
betonte wie gut es ist das Olaf Scholz
diese Regierung führt mit seiner
Erfahrung mit seiner um sich mit seiner
Ruhe führt ihr dieses Land sicher durch
und ich bin froh dass es genauso ist
vordergründig also eitel Sonnenschein
beschlossen wurde eine neue
digitalstrategie besprochen wurde vieles
von den Folgen des ukrainekrieges bis
hin zur Bildung
wir haben die wichtigen Themen der
Sicherheit besprochen was Energie was
äußere Sicherheit betrifft wir haben
Zukunftsfragen besprochen und wir haben
das in einer guten und sehr
konstruktiven Atmosphäre miteinander
getan nicht ganz so gut die Atmosphäre
beim Thema drittes Entlastungspaket
konkrete Ergebnisse gab es nicht
diskutiert wird weiter über eine direkte
Zahlung an Einkommen schwache über eine
Nachfolge für das 9-euro-ticket über die
Finanzierung wir brauchen ein wuchtiges
Paket für Entlastungen in der ganzen
Breite der Gesellschaft daran wird ja
auch gearbeitet zum anderen müssen wir
aber an die Wurzel der Probleme ran zum
Beispiel an den europäischen Strommarkt
hier rechnet der Kanzler mit einer
schnellen Reform und damit sinkenden
Preisen etwas finanzieller Spielraum für
Entlastungen sei vorhanden so Lindner
Robert Habeck setzt langfristig auf
alternative Energien
wir müssen diesen Winter überstehen als
Land als Gesellschaft als Ökonomie um
dann die Zukunft selbstbewusst und stark
zu gestalten möglicherweise noch in
dieser Woche will die Ampel dann
konkrete Ergebnisse vorlegen für das
dritte Entlastungspaket
jetzt zum Arbeitsmarkt der ist trotz
weltweiter krisenweiter robust die Zahl
der Arbeitslosen ist zwar stärker
gestiegen als jahreszeitlich üblich das
liege aber vor allem daran dass mehr
ukrainische geflüchtete in der Statistik
erfasst werden so die Bundesagentur für
Arbeit im August waren zwei Millionen
547.000 Menschen ohne Beschäftigung das
sind 77.000 mehr als im Vormonat die
Arbeitslosenquote stieg leicht auf 5,6
Prozent
die Verbraucherpreise im Euroraum sind
im August stärker gestiegen als erwartet
um 9,1 Prozent damit steigt der Druck
auf die Europäische Zentralbank die
Leitzinsen kräftig zu erhöhen die
Inflation wird besonders durch die
explodierenden Energiekosten getrieben
vor allem durch die Gaspreise und da ist
keine Entspannung in Sicht auch wenn
sich die Vorratsspeicher schneller
füllen als erwartet der russische
Staatskonzern Gazprom hat nämlich erneut
seine Lieferungen über die Pipeline Nord
Stream 1 gestoppt diesmal mindestens für
drei Tage angeblich wieder aus
technischen Gründen wie stehen wir
aktuell da in Sachen Energieversorgung
ein Überblick jetzt von Thaddäus Parade
hier vor der Küste in Wilhelmshaven
liegt das Bauprojekt das für mehr
Unabhängigkeit von russischem Erdgas
steht läuft alles nach Plan werden
flüssiggastanker von hier ihre Ladung
ins Deutsche Gasnetz einspeisen um für
die kommende Heizsaison gerüstet zu sein
müssen Deutschlands Gasspeicher
möglichst voll sein zu gut 83% sind sie
bereits gefüllt bis zum Winter sollte
der Füllstand mindestens 95% betragen
die Speicher sind schon mal deutlich
besser gefühlt als wir das auch
ursprünglich gedacht hatten wir bekommen
stabile gasflüsse aus Norwegen über
Belgien Holland demnächst Frankreich
aber es erhöht natürlich den Druck auch
einzusparen um gut über den Winter zu
kommen was aber passiert wenn der
russische Gashand zu bleibt eine
aktuelle Studie gibt Entwarnung es sei
zu schaffen vorausgesetzt Deutschland
reduziere seinen Gasverbrauch um 25%.
dazu müsste die Industrie ihren
Gasbedarf noch mehr runterfahren doch
weil jede zweite Wohnung in Deutschland
mit Gas beheizt wird könnte auch das
Absenken von ein paar Grad enorm viel
einsparen die Frage ist werden es die
Haushalte schaffen 15 20 Prozent ihre
Gasnachfrage zur reduzieren so oder so
Unabhängigkeit ist nur mit Flüssiggas zu
schaffen verbunden mit Kosten in
Milliardenhöhe ein Winter ohne
russisches Gas wäre also möglich fuckt
sich nur zu welchem Preis
in die Ukraine monatelang hatte die
Internationale Atomenergiebehörde Zugang
zum Atomkraftwerk sapo Geschirr
gefordert heute endlich ist ein Team aus
Spezialisten in der gleichnamigen Stadt
angekommen sie wollen überprüfen in
welchem Zustand die Russisch
kontrollierte Anlage ist dafür müssen
sie durch russisch besetztes Gebiet
fahren das erneut beschossen wurde die
Ukraine und Russland beschuldigen die
sich gegenseitig für Angriffe auf und
rund um das AKW
Henna Hebestreit ist für uns in
saporisha Henna für das iae-a-team sind
ungefähr anderthalb Autostunden bis zum
AKW wie gefährlich ist der Weg dorthin
jetzt wohne ich mir ganz so gefährlich
wie er vielleicht noch vor zwei Stunden
gewesen wäre wir konnten vor wenigen
Minuten mit dem Direktor der
Atomenergiebehörde grossi sprechen und
er sagt uns es sei jetzt mit Russland
alles geregelt Einzelheiten hatte uns
noch nicht verraten aber er sagte er
werde die Mission erst verlassen wenn
sie erfolgreich gewesen sei und sie
werde erfolgreich sein das sind schon
mal gute Nachrichten es ist die Aufgabe
auf jeden Fall eine nukleare Katastrophe
an dieser Atomanlage mitten im
Kriegsgebiet zu verhindern und den
Weiterbetrieb der Anlage sicherzustellen
morgen früh werden die Damen und Herren
aufbrechen und dann werden wir sehen was
dann vor Ort tatsächlich dabei
herauskommt danke für die aktuellen
Informationen nach saborischer Henna
Hebestreit war das die EU will es
russischen Staatsbürgern erschweren in
die EU einzureisen und wird ein Abkommen
mit Russland aussetzen dass die
Visa-Vergabe lange Zeit erleichterte die
reiseregel wurde von den
EU-Außenministern in Prag beschlossen
und ist Teil des sanktionspaketes gegen
Russland die Ukraine und einige
EU-Länder hatten sogar ein generelles
Einreiseverbot gefordert der Krieg in
der Ukraine auch Thema bei der
Vollversammlung des ökonomenischen Rates
der Kirchen in Karlsruhe eine Art
Welttreffen christlicher Kirchen und
Glaubensgemeinschaften zur Eröffnung
kritisierte Bundespräsident Steinmeier
die russisch-orthodoxe Kirche in
scharfer Form weil sie den russischen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
unterstützt außerdem rief Steinmeier zum
weltweiten Kampf gegen Antisemitismus
auf
[Applaus]
jahrzehntelang hat dieser Streit die
deutsch-israelischen Beziehungen
belastet jetzt gab es eine Einigung
quasi in letzter Minute kurz vor dem 50
jahrestag des Olympia Attentates haben
sich der Bund und die Hinterbliebenen
geeinigt auf eine Entschädigung und
darauf dass die Geschehnisse
aufgearbeitet werden die Angehörigen
werden voraussichtlich bei der
Gedenkfeier am Montag teilnehmen am 5
september
1972 hatten palästinensische Terroristen
in München die israelische Mannschaft
überfallen elf Mitglieder des Teams und
ein Polizist kamen ums Leben die
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen galten als
mangelhaft die Befreiungsaktion änderte
endete katastrophal
er hat
RAF-Terroristen verteidigt die Grünen
mitbegründet und erzählte zu den
politischen Charakterköpfen der Republik
Hans Christian Ströbele der langjährige
Bundestagsabgeordnete ist nun mit 83
Jahren in Berlin gestorben ein Mann der
oft anekte auch in seiner Partei Andreas
Huppert erinnert
so kannte man ihn radeln dem
Regierungsviertel Hans-Christian
Ströbele unterwegs mit Fahrrad in Sachen
grüner Politik seine Motivation dabei
immer
ich will die Welt verändern und die
Gesellschaft
das will ich schon seit den 60er Jahren
Ströbele Jahrgang 1939 in Halle an der
Saale geboren aufgewachsen im
westfälischen Markt als Sohn eines
Chemikers und einer Juristin studierte
ab 1960 erst in Heidelberg dann in
Berlin Jura und Politik
er wird Anwalt seine Strafverteidigung
von RAF-Mitgliedern verleiht ihm
gemeinsam mit Otto Schilly Anfang der
70er Jahre eine bundesweite
Aufmerksamkeit politisch gehört Ströbele
zur außerparlamentarischen
linksalternativen Bewegung
1985 schließt er sich der Berliner
Alternativen Liste an die später im
Landesverband der Grünen aufgeht
1990 schaffte es an die Spitze der
Bundespartei wird als Partei linke einer
von zwei Vorsitzenden allerdings nur
knapp ein Jahr lang erst 1998 geht’s
zurück auf die bundespolitische Bühne
und wie er holt in Berlin-Kreuzberg das
erste grüne Direktmandat für den
Bundestag
Hans-Christian Ströbele links beharrlich
und immer gerne auch unbequem die Welt
die er verbessern wollte die muss nun
ohne ihn auskommen
jetzt in die USA wo die Rakete für die
Mondmission Artemis 1 immer noch in
Warteposition steht jetzt will die
US-Weltraumbehörde Nase einen neuen
Versuch starten
Samstagabend unserer Zeit die unbemannte
Rakete sollte schon am Montag abheben
wegen technischer Probleme wurde die
Mission aber kurz vor dem Start
abgebrochen sollte der Testflug gelingen
will die Nase ab 2025 wieder Menschen
zum Mond bringen
wir sind beim Sport und bei Rudi kein
richtig guter Tag fürs Tennis heute fürs
deutsche Tennis stimmt absolut sieben
deutsche ausgeschieden von 8 in der
ersten Runde der US Open als einzige hat
Jule Niemeyer die zweite Runde erreicht
die Dortmunderinnen gewann ihr Match
gegen die US-Amerikanerin Sofia kennen
mit 7 zu 6 und 6 zu 4 für Andrea
Petkovic war es ein letzter großer
Auftritt voller Emotionen sie beendete
ihre Karriere
nach würdevoll knapper Niederlage gegen
die Weltranglisten 13 Belinda Bencic
flossen erstmal Tränen auch später noch
in der Pressekonferenz
noch immer spielt sie großartiges Tennis
aber kaum mehr ohne Schmerzmittel der
Verschleiß in 16 profi-jahren hat auch
vor der gestern noch mal gefeiert eine
Andrea Petkovic nicht Halt gemacht wenn
mein Körper
20-jähriger Körper für immer wäre dann
würde ich auch noch 35 Jahre Tennis
spielen ist einfach das was ich immer
machen wollte und was mir die meiste
Freude und das meiste die meiste Energie
im Leben gegeben hat so aber fand die
knapp 35-Jährige nun den Mut zum
Absprung mit zahlreichen Glanzpunkten
obwohl sie mental durchaus angeschlagen
in dieses Match ging die letzten sechs
Tage habe ich nur geheult ich weiß nicht
ob das der richtige Abschied ist
wahrscheinlich nicht zum Abschied gegen
benchic hätte man ihr den riesigen
centercode gegönnt aber auch auf Platz 7
wurde sie gebührend gefeiert unter Petko
Petko rufen zeigte sie sich noch einmal
ihren Fans
sie wird vermisst werden so viel steht
fest
zum Fußball mit einem Offensiv-Feuerwerk
hat RB Leipzig die zweite Runde im
DFB-Vereinspokal erreicht der Titel
Verteidiger setzte sich gegen Teutonia
Ottensen klar mit 8:0 durch Leipzig
Rückkehrer Timo Werner glänzte vor
Spielfreude und erzielte allein drei
Treffer herausragend bei diesem Tore
Festival auch Emil Forsberg der den
schönsten Treffer erzielte nachdem er
zuvor bereits zwei Werner Tore
vorbereitet hatte
die deutschen Volleyballer bangen bei
der WM in Polen und Slowenien um den
Einzug ins Achtelfinale im letzten
Gruppenspiel unterlag die Mannschaft
Gastgeber und Vize Europameister
Slowenien deutlich mit 0 zu 3 nach zwei
Niederlagen in drei Spielen hat die
Auswahl das Weiterkommen nicht mehr in
eigener Hand muss auf die Mithilfe der
Konkurrenz hoffen aber das scheint zu
klappen die Chancen sind nämlich gar
nicht so schlecht
und das war es vom Sport dann vielen
Dank Rudi wir blicken jetzt noch auf die
Zahlen vom Mittwochslotto und die gehen
so 15 11 18 24 37 und die Superzahl
lautet 7 weitere Gewinnzahlen auf
lotto.zdf.de und auf der ZDF Textseite
er spätsommerlich als frühherbstlich
beginnt morgen der September mehr gleich
von Katja horneffer zum heute-journal um
21 Uhr ist Christian Sievers wieder für
Sie da das waren die Nachrichten an
diese Mittwoch danke fürs zuschauen
entspannten Abend gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend es hat geregnet das kommt in
diesem dürresommer ja einer Nachricht
gleich und Programm gemäß ist dieser
Regen auch weiter nach Osten gezogen und
am Nachmittag lockerten die Wolken im
Westen schon wieder auf es 24 bis 80
Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter im
Schwarzwald oder auch auf der
Schwäbischen Alb und auch jetzt in der
Nacht regnet es noch etwas zwischen dem
Bayerischen Wald und dem Alpenrand
einzelne Schauer gibt es an der Ostsee
oder an der Mosel bei 14 bis 8 Grad und
morgen ist das Wetter recht freundlich
einzelne Schauer gibt es an der Ostsee
der Regen am Alpenrand lässt nach und
die Temperaturen steigen auf Werte von
19 Grad am Alpenrand bis zu 27 Grad am
Rhein in den nächsten Tagen geht es im
Süden und Südwesten immer mal wieder
Regenschauer und Gewitter im Norden
bleibt es dagegen trocken und die
Temperaturen liegen bei 20 bis 29 Grad
guten Abend